thank you for this opportunity
to
share information from south africa
overall what worries us is that we have
a system in place to look at
re-infections
um so if we monitor using our testing
database a database that has pcr and
antigen tests for the whole country both
the public and the private sector we
monitor
the first test and then we can see the
other tests as they come in and we call
a re-infection another test from the
same individual 90 days after the first
positive test
we monitored these re-infections for the
beta and for the delta wave and we
didn't see an increase in re-infections
over and above what we expect when the
force of infection changes when the wave
stops however we are seeing an increase
for omicron and that sort of speaks to
the fact
that in our population with a high
seroprevalence
so we many people have a previous
infection
we believe that that previous infection
does not provide them
protection from infection due to omicron
however
hopefully
provides them from
protect
provides them with protection against
severe disease
hospital admissions and death
so i think that's the first message and
data are becoming available are being
released by the nicd and will be shared
trying to show these preliminary
analyses trying to understand omicron in
the country but i think that's the first
message and people talk about increased
transmissibility but i think in this
case this virus might be as
transmissible its own characteristics
the virus characteristics may be very
similar or slightly less than delta in
in spreading which or being able to be
contagious however it's the
it's the susceptibility of the
population that is greater now because
previous infection used to protect
against delta and now with omicron it
doesn't seem to be the case
we believe that vaccines will still
however protect against severe disease
because we've seen this decrease in
protection using vaccines
with the other variants but the vaccines
have always held out to prevent
severe disease
and admission into hospitals and death
and that's the reason why our final
message really about this variant is
to consider
the
the basic principles of what we should
be doing we should be vaccinating as
many people as we can so that they can
have vaccine-induced protection
in addition we should be using our
non-pharmaceutical interventions um
trying to remember to use masks to use
the the fresh air that we have um and
ventilation and to prevent um and to
avoid
gatherings of large numbers of people in
unventilated spaces